ah oh my god oh my god huh we're in New
York subway what is wrong my hand
[Music]
ha it's not even you said 30 apart Stroh
she's just what cook that's me
what dude this guy's this guy is creepy
looking like he is the scary part of
this game oh [ __ ] but this is a slug
tail it's disgusting
oh my god oh god what do i do I do
no no no no no no no no no no I'm dying
ah Jesus Christ
whew so cuz when you're backing up shop
why do you walk so slow move faster No
Oh back you're back you're back you're
back that's probably where I need to go
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
God Jesus that's our shoulder ha ha oh
good there's my shoulder god dammit why
am i back into my body
I don't like this thing oh okay this is
a bad idea this is a bad idea I'm out
No Oh Oh mad a bit um get them good
batteries back oh my god go oh God
don't follow me no no no no no I don't
understand why like people play this for
pleasure this is not pleasurable for me
I have this little you're following me
yeah it's like rubbing his weenie
get out of here you pervert he's trying
to sex me all right I think you're
friendly but holy are you scariest for
some reason I feel a lot better because
because you're with me
Oh done back oh my god you look like
Nick ah Jesus Christ
well I'm out of here dude that thing
that thing jumped out and I've been lost
it if it hurts
Oh